so there's a recent paper in science was
published about a month ago when I first
saw it I didn't really understand what
it was about but when I understood it
which was reading a simpler explanation
in another magazine and then coming back
to it it's really fascinating and I want
to tell you about it it begins with a
really rather boring reaction which
tells people quite a bit about how atoms
react so imagine a molecule of h2 which
has two hydrogen atoms bonded together
and they bring up another atom comes in
in bangs into it and this hydrogen atom
flies away so it's h plus h 2 goes to h
2 plus h what they wanted to do in this
paper was to study the effect of using
different isotopes of hydrogen which
have different weights and you can get
deuterium atoms which weighs twice as
much and if you want radioactives you
can get pretty
mattum which weighs three times as much
as a hydrogen atom so you can have a
bigger one that comes along boom like
that the problem is that if you want to
have a heavier atom still say helium
helium can't react let me explain to you
why in the middle of an atom of hydrogen
there's a nucleus which has an electron
going round it and so each of these
hydrogen atoms has one electron which
bond together and if another hydrogen
comes along with one electron they can
swap partners and this one goes off with
its one electron helium has two
electrons going around it so when helium
comes along with its two electrons it
can't displace hydrogen because two
electrons are coming in and only one is
going out and this is where they did a
really clever experiment the authors of
this paper they disguised Healy
so it became like hydrogen and before I
read this paper I would have said that's
impossible but let me explain they used
a particle called a muon a negative knew
on which is a different sort of particle
bit like an electron has the same charge
but is much heavier so in a new particle
accelerator you can accelerate muons and
they will hit helium atoms knock out one
of the electrons and take its place so
then you have a nucleus one muon and one
electron but because the muon is very
heavy it's very close to the nucleus
leaving the electron much further out so
when the hydrogen bangs into it this one
leaves and you have a molecule which has
helium with muon and hydrogen and I
would never believed such a reaction
could take place and that's what made me
excited again and again for scientists
if they hear something surprising that
makes them think in a different way it's
really good your mind is a bit like soup
it has to be stirred up all the time and
then interesting vegetables float to the
surface and so on and you have new ideas
if you just sit there it all stagnates
and gets boring they have a strange
symbol in this paper they call it
hydrogen 4.1 which is quite a strange
notation I've never seen it before it's
a molecule that nobody's ever made
before and it will only be stable for
some minut fraction of a second it's
long enough to do the measurement of the
rate of the reaction and test the
theories of how atoms react